at a time when it seems like every movie
in history is being considered for a
remake or reboot the horror genre has
found itself particularly ripe for
pillaging sometimes it takes more than
just one attempt to get it right for
proof just queue up these horror remakes
that actually turned out better than the
original films The Evil Dead the horror
genre wouldn't be the same without Sam
Raimi's 1981 classic The Evil Dead made
on a shoestring budget with no name
actors the film used gorilla special
effects and wildly inventive camerawork
to sell its story many fans who were
still stunned by the failed remakes of
Nightmare on Elm Street and Friday the
13th were understandably skeptical when
the 2013 Evil Dead remake was announced
what they didn't know was that director
fede alvarez his new version which Raimi
produced would turn out to be one of the
best horror films of the decade I'm
really excited to see something that I
care about really deeply being reborn by
a great artist the 2013 film is tense
well acted and efficiently paced with
the kind of jaw-dropping practical
effects Hollywood hadn't seen in years a
ridiculously underrated film and an
improvement on the beloved but
understandably flawed original The Hills
Have Eyes French filmmaker Alex and Raja
are in his ticket to Hollywood with his
stylish Lea effective 2003 film high
tension in turn he was handed the remake
of West Cravens 1977 cult classic The
Hills Have Eyes released in 2006 the
film garnered middling reviews despite
being a stylish and effective as high
tension and ratcheting the gore way up
not that the remake is a great film but
it's far more effective than the
original which may be the most overrated
horror film ever Cravens Hills was
released before the advent of home video
when a film's legend often grew by word
of mouth which is likely why the
original Hills is remembered as anything
but laughably inept
luckily seven years later Craven crafted
a true classic Nightmare on Elm Street
the crazies George a Romero's is a
revered filmmaker for one simple reason
he created zombies as we know them
introducing the concept in his
low-budget masterpiece Night of the
Living Dead
but with 1973's the crazies he branched
out with the story about inhabitants of
a small town turning into maniacs when
exposed to an experimental virus
unfortunately the only place the film
ever gained much of an audience was the
video store it was a box-office failure
because it wasn't very good the 2010
remake was the sophomore effort of
sahara filmmaker breck eisner
understandably nobody was expecting much
from the retelling of a little loved
decades-old film but what they got was a
shockingly well made superbly
photographed and at times unbearably
tense film that bears little resemblance
to its schlocky b-movie namesake
remaking Romero is hardly ever a great
idea but eisenerz The Crazies is simply
excellent in its own right is he dead
funny games with his 1997 German
language horror film funny games Michael
Haneke he wanted to challenge the
audience implicating them an on-screen
carnage in a way that no film had before
it's an excellent and disturbing piece
and many of its fans saw the 2007 remake
also directed by Hana key a nearly
shot-for-shot recreation of the original
as completely unnecessary but by a
slight margin it's the superior film one
could go so far as to say the 2007
version is the one Hana kee intended to
make in the first place
since his goal was to target an American
audience something the original failed
to do it also benefits from a pair of
truly talented leads in Naomi Watts and
Tim Roth the debate around this oddly
unique pair of films will likely never
be settled and they're both fantastic
but the 2007 version is ever so slightly
better Silent House the 2010 Uruguayan
film La Casa muda shot entirely on a
$6,000 budget is quite an achievement
it's edited to appear as if it's one
continuous 88th minute shot following a
young woman who's shown up to help
renovate a creepy old house the single
take gimmick is well done but the film
suffers from the rough edges you'd
expect from a shoestring production with
an unknown cast by contrast the 2011
remake Silent House benefits from
putting its star elizabeth Olsen front
and center in every shot Olsen
completely sells the mounting terrorists
things go from weird in the first act to
terrifying in the second act to sanity
shattering in the third Silent House is
a heavy-duty upgrade to its ultra-low
budget predecessor not to mention
criminally underrated we are what we are
the 2010 Mexican film somos Loki I was a
confounding piece of work a dark
brooding well made psycho drama about a
family of cannibals it was well received
but suffered from a tone that some
called relentlessly humorless and
fielded a cast that at times was less
than engaging the English language 2013
version borrows the basic premise of the
original but not much else it trades the
2010 films urban setting for the
backwoods of the deep south injecting an
American gothic feel that's much more
appropriate for the lurid subject matter
director Jim Mickle uses the material to
raise questions about the dangers of
tradition and religion that were
completely absent from the original
indie trades that film's ending for one
of the most bizarre haunting conclusions
of any horror film this decade we are
what we are might not exactly scare your
pants off but it will stick with you
long after viewing top 10 stars ready
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our youtube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to
[Music]